nouveau numéro de reporter sur France 24
et une fois n'est pas coutume nous vous
emmenons 80 ans en arrière à Marseille
en 1943 nous sommes en pleine Seconde
Guerre mondiale les Allemands occupent
la ville depuis quelques mois en janvier
presque jour pour jour il y a 80 ans
dans les quartiers populaires autour du
Vieux-Port le cœur historique de
Marseille la résistance s'organise et
multiplie les actions ces vieux
quartiers concentrent des populations
pauvres
issues de l'immigration notamment des
Italiens fuyant le régime de Mussolini
des syndicalistes des communistes et une
communauté juive tout ce qui te l'air et
les nazis exècres ils vont décider de
faire de Marseille un exemple évacuer la
population 25000 personnes on en
envoyant une partie dans les camps de
concentration et raser le quartier 1500
immeubles détruits 50 rue rayées de la
carte aujourd'hui les descendants de ces
familles se battent pour faire
reconnaître un crime contre l'humanité
Marseille 1943 le crime oublié c'est un
document signé Florence gaillard pour
France 24
[Musique]
derrière moi se trouve l'hôtel de ville
de Marseille qui date du 17e siècle
c'est un des derniers vestiges du
quartier tout autour qui était le
quartier Saint-Jean qui a été
complètement rasé par les nazis en 1943
on peut voir des immeubles sur la façade
du port ce sont des immeubles qui ont
été reconstruits en 1955 sur les ruines
du quartier 50 rue ont complètement
disparu du coeur de Marseille l'endroit
où les premiers marseillais se sont
installés dans son histoire
[Musique]
c'est moi c'est mon papa mais là je dois
avoir 3 ans mon point de vue et là mon
père il est là coiffeur là
il était coordonné en Sicile avait
appris deux métiers il avait appris le
métier de cordonnier et de et de
coiffeur
mes parents qu'ils étaient partis de
Sicile en 1922 chassé par bossolini la
fascisme qui s'est installés en Italie
moi j'étais fils unique né le 24
novembre
1937 au 66 rue Saint-Laurent à Marseille
je m'appelle Fernand Ribéry je suis né
le 18 janvier 1950 et je suis le
petit-fils de Francisco commental mort
au camp de concentration en Allemagne
piqûre de sel c'est à dire qu'il
débarrassait les coques d'un navire du
sel qui s'était aggloméré dessus il est
père de 6 enfants
donc ils vivent 16 rue de la Reynarde
qui fait partie du quartier d'y réservé
c'est à dire c'est le quartier de la
prostitution
un quartier très populaire la rue était
notre terrain de jeu et le souvenirs ce
sont des petites rues très étroites mais
il y avait au centre de la rue un petit
caniveau on faisait la course de bateau
soit avec du papier soit avec des
bouchons on était peut-être pauvre mais
on était heureux voilà
[Musique]
je nie à Marseille sur ce qu'on appelle
aujourd'hui le quartier du Vieux-Port
maman elle vient de Grèce mon père lui
c'est
Istanbul ils sont arrivés très jeunes en
France ils sont naturalisés peu après
leur arrivée il s'installerait de la
Rose où nous sommes nés tous les trois
mon frère ma sœur et moi
et très vite ils ont une petite
entreprise qui est prospère ma mère
également s'intéresse au commerce elle
va vendre des vêtements
[Musique]
c'est un quartier où les gens
s'entraident beaucoup peuplés réellement
des migrés
[Musique]
les Allemands au cube Marseille à partir
du 11 novembre 1942 ils ont franchi une
démarcation pour aller en quelque sorte
à la rencontre des alliés qui ont
débarqué en Afrique du Nord
[Musique]
le 3 janvier du 143 il y a des actions
armées de la résistance qui ont lieu à
l'Hôtel splendide et dans des maisons de
passe un des vieux quartiers Hitler
semble-t-il à une colère énorme sur ce
qui se passe à Marseille en disant il
faut à tout prix faire un exemple et
pour les Allemands les vieux quartiers
concentrent tout ce qui est le contraire
du nazisme du genre le chancre sont des
mots qu'ils emploient le chancre de
l'Europe c'est à dire un lieu de
dégénérescence absolu alors les
objectifs de l'opération qu'on va
appeler l'opération sultan sont définies
par himler lui-même dans un télégramme
qui prévoit la destruction des vieux
quartiers en faisant sauter les
habitants dans leur domicile
[Musique]
des autorités françaises en particulier
René Bousquet protestent en disant vous
pouvez pas faire sauter les Marseillais
en même temps que leur que leurs
habitats mais en même temps
l'état de Vichy collabore avec les nazis
[Musique]
les 22 23 et 24 janvier 1943 et les
Français du gouvernement de Vichy ont
décidé en concertation avec les nazis de
vider ce quartier et sa population les
25000 personnes complètement évacuées de
force ma numiditary par les policiers
français réquisitionnés en normes sur
tout le territoire 12000 seront utilisés
pour la rafle du Vieux-Port et au petit
matin du 24 janvier 1943 des voitures
haut-parleurs vont sillonner le quartier
et vont diffuser un terrible message
évacuer complètement vos habitations
prenez quelques affaires quelques vivre
pour 48 heures et fermez bien à clé
[Musique]
cette nouvelle je dormais bien entendu à
6h du matin en tant que je dormais ma
maman est venue me réveiller en me
disant habile toi vite parce qu'il faut
que ça n'aille qu'on parte de suite j'ai
vu le visage de mes parents très
décomposé
par la peur la crainte l'anxiété voilà
alors je ça ça m'a marqué quand même
mais une fois qu'on sort dans
l'appartement avec tous les autres je
dirais habitants du quartier on est
rassemblé dans la rue en cas de par la
flèche française on nous a fait
descendre la rue Saint-Laurent pour nous
emmener sur sur le sur le quai du porte
comme un troupeau de moutons comme
métropole et personne
réagissait parce que si c'était les
Allemands qui étaient venus taper à la
porte comme ça il y aurait eu
certainement une résistance
la veille un ami aux parents vient les
voir
et diamant père isolant
inquiéter les Juifs dans le quartier
mais également à l'Opéra
et vous devriez vous analer vous cacher
par lassez dans le quartier pendant
quelques temps on parle pas de
destructions il est pas au courant tout
ça
mon père en parle réunion de famille et
il décide de pas prendre ça au sérieux
en disant mais non les Juifs sont
inquiétés beaucoup plus haut en France
la rafla commence
mon père
son frère
son beau-frère
on est revu on y verra pas
[Musique]
sur le quai du port qui était à l'époque
qui est maréchal Pétain là les attentes
des tramways des bus qui sont
réquisitionnés en membres pour
transporter 15000 personnes parmi les
25000 habitants du quartier d'abord à la
gare d'Arenc qui est une gare de triage
près du port pour les envoyer à Fréjus
dans le camp militaire de Fréjus des
commissions allemandes des militaires
sur la base de fichiers français vont
composer une commission de criblage on
va cribler les Juifs on va cribler les
opposants politiques les communistes et
parmi eux des jeunes gens dont on n'a
pas compris pourquoi ils avaient été
choisis si ce n'est pour un besoin de
main d'oeuvre dans les camps de
concentration en Allemagne
[Musique]
on nous a mis dans des baraquements
insalubre il y avait pas de lit
c'était de la paille souillée
avec les bestioles des vermines tout ce
que vous voulez et c'était là-dessus
qu'il fallait que norme on a séparé donc
les les papas des mamans et des enfants
ma mère disait que mon grand-père venait
les voir tous les soirs
il lui apportait des Pignes de pain
qu'il avait fait griller pour que
les distribue à ses frères et ses soeurs
au bout d'une semaine on nous a informés
que de nous préparer qu'on allait
rentrer à Marseille à ma grand-mère
rentre avec ses 6 enfants
elle le on ne sait pas ce qu'il est
advenu du papa ou du grand-père
ce qui se dit c'est que il va rentrer
et d'une semaine à l'autre il ne
rentrait pas et il a il a fallu se
résoudre à l'édidas c'est qu'il avait
disparu
[Musique]
ce qui a Fréjus n'ont pas été
sélectionné heureusement peuvent rentrer
à Marseille seulement
la plupart arrive trop tard les
destructions ont déjà commencé et les
immeubles tombés ils ne reverront jamais
leur habitation ne récupérons aucun bien
[Musique]
au total 1500 immeubles ont été détruits
sur 14 hectares 50 rue ont disparu de la
carte entre le 1er février et le 17
février 1943 le soir en explosé et la
journée en déblayé
[Musique]
il y a des personnalités fortes c'est le
curé Caillol qui va écrire
au cabinet du Maréchal Pétain plusieurs
lettres il y a même un pasteur qui sera
déporté parce qu'il a protesté donc dans
l'ensemble la population était effrayée
aussi en disant on commence par le port
mais où est-ce qu'ils vont s'arrêter
il y a un bureau où on donne des
renseignements sur les gens qui ont été
pris
maman part avec une très grosse somme
d'argent dans son sac qu'est-ce qu'elle
a un esprit reste en payant elle va
pouvoir retrouver son époux et le reste
de la famille qui a été amené ça se
passe ça comme ça on l'envoie pas elle
va assez de moi Drancy
alors que mon père est pris en janvier
il mourra très vite en mars maman va
rester deux mois de rempli d'où elle
peut écrire des courriers ce qui est
stupéfiant c'est que dans les deux cas
quand ils arrivent en transit
entre le jour de leur arrivée et le jour
de leur décès il ne se passe que 6 jours
[Musique]
en janvier 2019 j'ai déposé au nom de
quatre survivants et de 4 descendants
une plainte pour crime contre l'humanité
parce que les nazis et les Français se
sont concertés ils ont attaqué
systématiquement ce quartier en visant
un groupe de population civile
c'est-à-dire les habitants du quartier
dans un périmètre déterminé à l'avance
cela abouti évidemment à la mort la
déportation les transferts forcés les
destructions les pertes de bien etc tout
cela c'est la définition même des crimes
contre l'humanité
nous avons perdu et le toit pour nous
abriter et le salon de coiffure je
travaille qui nous faisait et qui nous
faisait vivre quoi ça a été je dirais un
drame ça a été le début d'une misère
noire parce que nous avions brillé on
était nu et cru comme on dit
[Musique]
il est on a su à posteriori qui avait
été
sélectionné pour faire partie d'un
convoi de 800 personnes environ la
destination du cambienne et au mois
d'avril
destination quand nous concentration à
nouveau en Allemagne
voilà
ma conviction c'est qu'il était engagé
syndicalement aux politiquesment et que
c'est pour cette raison que les
Allemands ne sélectionnés
maman
Maurice Jacqueline et moi il y a mon
frère ma sœur qui ont survécu moi et
surtout maman maman j'ai jamais connu
alors quand je me vois tout frisé tout
blanc sur ses genoux je me dis mais oui
tu la connaissais mais quel souvenir tu
en as aucun
la trouve vraiment jolie
[Musique]
et voilà pour ce document signé Florence
gaillard avec georgièsbeck à la caméra
vous pouvez retrouver ce reporter sur le
site de France 24 merci d'avoir suivi
cette émission et on se retrouve la
semaine prochaine pour un nouveau numéro
de reporter
[Musique]